Welcome back everyone this is charlie they
just released a bunch of scenes for the new
spider-man madame webb movie that they're filming
we also learned a lot about several versions of
spider-man from the multiverse that'll be in the
movie like many many versions of spider-man so
i'll explain what's going on because a character
like madame webb just in general is like the next
big step towards true live-action spider-man into
the spider-verse spider-man no way home is about
as close as you could get to that up to this point
with toby maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man and their villains coming into the
mcu but you can see how they're trying to build
towards a more legit live-action spider-verse
movie if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos of course i'll
do more spider-man videos as we get more details
about the movie obviously we have spider-man 4
they're working on with tom holland behind the
scenes that's going to be a couple years before
that happens that's why it wasn't on the marvel
phase 5 or marvel phase 6 schedules just because
tom holland like recently left social media just
to take time for himself away there's probably
going to be about three years between spider-man
no way home and spider-man 4. but while that's
going on you have all these other spider-man
films that sony and marvel are working on kevin
feige does help them with some of the movies
some movies like morbius for instance kevin feige
not involved with quite so much it is definitely
not morbid time but i will explain how all these
are connected because sony and marvel like trying
to keep all this as connected as possible without
lumping too much on the mcu like some of it will
be connected to the mcu and some of it will be
like sony doing stuff on their own most of the
madame web movie seems like it takes place about
20 years ago in the early 2000s just based on all
the easter eggs and the technology and all the
scenes that they've been filming that we saw
and people are starting to think of it as like
a spider-man movie with a terminator style plot
based on the characters like a version of doctor
octopus or like another sinister six character
in the future sending someone back in time to
kill peter parker's spider-man before he's born
so i know there's lots of questions about which
version of peter parker we're talking about which
earth does this take place on i believe this is
meant to take place on the same earth as the venom
in the morbius movies just because it's taking
place in the marvel sony universe primarily and
they want most of their movies to take place on
the same earth like they've already clarified that
all the venom movies in the morbius movies take
place on the same earth ages that this is taking
place much earlier in the timeline dakota johnson
is playing cassandra webb a version of madame webb
in the movie or version of spider-woman depending
on how you think about her she's had many
different names in the comics so if we're talking
about terminator plot with spider-man characters
she'd be like the kyle reese type of figure trying
to save peter parker's mother to help him be born
eventually while she's pregnant with him i'm reece
searching techcon bn38416 a sign to protect you
you've been targeted for termination emma roberts
is supposed to be playing a version of mary parker
peter parker's mother you can see she's pregnant
while they're filming scenes it sounds like she's
pregnant with peter parker while this is happening
that's why we're talking about terminator plot
here because during the terminator movie the
terminator tried to come back to kill sarah
connor so that she could not eventually give birth
to john connors like i said the movie takes place
primarily in the new york city area about 20
years ago that's why all the sets the cabs the
palm pilots the 3g internet connection all over
the place the beyonce picture all seemed like
it come from the early 2000s they'll use a lot
of cg in the backgrounds here to tune things so
that it just seems even more like the early 2000s
like we're talking about the same era as the toby
maguire spider-man movie we also see a version
of the daily bugle truck with a dailybugle.com
like the web address in front of the four-star
diner that's also from the spider-man comics
even though the logo seems a little bit different
they've sort of mixed and matched a lot of the
daily bugle logos across spider-man films like
they might explain the daily bugle logo changed
a little bit over the past 20 years because if
this takes place in the same earth as the venom
movies we saw in venom let the b carnage that they
have a version of tobey maguire's daily bugle logo
we also know that sony isn't great when they're
mixing and matching a lot of easter eggs and they
don't always have like a super solid plan for how
they're gonna connect all these easter eggs so
even if this is on the same earth and some of the
logos and some of the easter eggs don't seem like
they completely match up with what's happening
in the future in the venom movies for instance
don't worry about that that's mostly sony just
mixing things up kind of like they did when they
released the original morbius trailers in the
four star diner from the spiderman comics it's
just like a 1950s style diner that peter parker
and his friends hung out at while they were in
college so this would just be the diner earlier
in the timeline in the early 2000s but in this
scene here you can see dakota johnson's cassandra
webb madame webb wearing julia carpenter's comic
book outfit like the jacket here right out of
the comic book look sydney sweeney is actually
supposed to be playing julia carpenter i believe
so she might give julia the jacket later in the
movie because in the comics eventually madame webb
basically passes all of her powers to julia this
is just meant to confirm the look they're going
with for her character at least at the beginning
of the movie because when most people think of
madame webb they think of the older madame webb
from the spider-man the animated series episodes
or from spider-man shattered dimensions which
itself is a spider-verse game then in a bunch
of other scenes you see cassandra webb with adam
scott's character who's reportedly playing a young
version of uncle ben ben parker dressed as emt's
saving people at a car wreckage where one is
falling off a bridge everybody's been wondering
since andrew garfield spider-man the next time
we're going to see a version of uncle ben because
they kind of skipped over that during the mcu tom
hall and spider-man movies later you can see that
same ambulance driving past the news truck this
says daily globe on the side that's also from the
spider-man comics the daily globe which is like a
rival news organization for the daily bugle like
the daily bugle was not the only news organization
in the new york city area in the spider-man comics
then you see emma robert's character pregnant
like i said she's reportedly playing a version
of mary parker peter parker's mother pregnant
with him she's uncle ben's sister-in-law peter
parker's father richard parker was uncle ben's
biological brother so that's the connection
so theoretically someone from the future like
another sinister six villain if we're talking
about the villain that i think that we're talking
about it'd be a version of doctor octopus from the
future behind this sending someone back in time
to stop peter parker spider-man from being born
just because of all the things he'll do
in the future when he becomes spider-man
one of madame webb's main abilities and this might
be the way she figures out what her powers are at
the beginning of the movie depending on where
she picks up in the timeline is clairvoyance
prescience and the ability to sense others
and when changes to the timeline are happening
because it does seem like there's a lot of
crazy time travel stuff happening in this movie
and even though we don't have footage of the
others yet the other versions of spider-man
and spider-woman i guess you could say in
the movie are sydney sweeney like i said
who's playing a version of julia carpenter who
becomes a version of spider-woman eventually
she also becomes a version of madame webb
taking the mantle from the original madame web
celeste o'connor is supposed to be playing a
version of maddie franklin she became another
version of spider-woman eventually then isabella
merced is playing a version of anya corazon
who is a version of spider-girl in the comics the
way she got her powers is that another hunter who
was part of a group called the spider society
granted her powers using a ritual her spider-man
powers are just like a little bit different but
very similar to spider-man's like she can grow an
exoskeleton but for the most part they're similar
to peter parker's spider-man's powers now there is
a separate jessica drew spider-woman movie that
sony is working on right now but that's like a
completely separate thing i don't know if she's
also going to have a crossover in this movie since
they've been saying that most of these movies
take place on the same earth as the venom movies
there's some reports in speculation the villain of
the movie and if we're calling this like a madame
web spider-man terminator type of movie that the
terminator of this equation like the villain of
the film will be a version of charlotte witter
who's madame webb's granddaughter in the comics
like from later in the timeline who eventually
gets spider-man-based powers from dr octopus in
the future so i guess that the movie is adapting a
version of this comic story like if they're really
doing it then dr octopus in the future technically
would be the real villain which would make
sense for those of you asking which version of
peter parker spider-man is this like that's a
big question too because we're all wondering if
they're going to be building up to a version of
spider-man they literally referenced it during the
morbius movie post-credits scene who's it going to
be they might say that it's a totally new actor
playing the character just because of when it
takes place in the timeline in the year of peter
parker's birth like it was the early 2000s and
he's like just about to be born tobey maguire
spider-man for example was a teenager already
getting his powers when this movie is supposed to
be taking place in andrew garfield spider-man is
only slightly younger than that so i'm assuming
it's not either of their versions of peter parker
sony does want to bring both toby maguire and
andrew garfield back in the future like we've had
all kinds of theories about them bringing andrew
garfield back but i think they also are trying to
find a way to connect with the mcu movies as much
as possible like so they can use tom holland's
version of spider-man because technically
sony owns the character into this big sharing
arrangement with marvel and technically the age
of this peter parker spider-man in the madame web
movie would be similar to the age of tom holland's
peter parker just given his age in captain america
civil war when he gets his powers in the timeline
so they might be trying to say that this version
of mary parker is giving birth to tom holland's
peter parker spider-man or one that looks like
him but that's just an early theory right now they
could just as easily say it's like a completely
different actor playing the character but when we
talk about larger crossover like larger spider-man
plans in the mcu and the sony movies we have
avengers 5 kang dynasty in avengers 6 secret wars
very big multiverse based movies we also know they
eventually plan on crossing tom hardy's venom over
with tom hall and spider-man they have the post
credit scene where he left a piece of the venom
symbiote setting up a big symbiote saga starting
with spider-man 4 with tom holland in the mcu
what they might do with this next symbiose saga in
the mcu though is culminated in avengers 6 secret
wars like during secret wars he'll be in the venom
costume and they'll try to do as many classic
spider-man secret wars alien costume easter
eggs is possible spider-man originally got the
venom symbiote during the 1980s version of secret
wars which was a different storyline from the one
they're going to be doing in the mcu but he had
damaged his normal costume so he went to repair
it using this alien technology and it basically
gave him the venom symbiote so a lot of what was
happening during that initial venom storyline is
eventually going to be happening in the mcu just
slightly different way that it all comes together
just because of the way they're doing the movies
but everybody post all your theories in the
comments below what do you think is going on
during this madam web movie with this terminator
peter parker spider-man type of plot and how
they're going to pay off the symbiote saga in
secret wars eventually big reminder that she-hulk
episodes are starting my she-hulk episode one
video is going to post next make sure you enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss that
there's supposed to be a pretty epic post credit
scene for episode one but there are post credit
scenes in every single episode and just all kinds
of easter eggs and references so there'll be a lot
of zooming and enhancing everyone click here for
my new loki season 2 first look video and click
here for my new she-hulk trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!